salut c'est Hugo cette semaine dans la
grande histoire je voulais vous partager
le 3e et dernier épisode de notre série
documentaire consacré au skined on est
au milieu des années 80 les skinad
sèment la terreur dans les rues de Paris
mais ils vont devoir faire face à de
nouvelles bandes qu'on appelle les
chasseurs de skin parmi eux il y a les
duky boys une bande violente politisée
et surentraînée au même moment les
skinet gagnent les tribunes des stades
au Parc des Princes ils vont initier la
mouvance houigan et la tribune Boulogne
va devenir leur bastion pour comprendre
comment ce mouvement a basculé on a fait
le choix d'aller aussi interroger les
plus extrêmes d'entre eux pour vous
montrer qui ils sont
[Musique]
réellement on était jeune et qu'on est
un petit peu alcoolisé un petit
peu des amphétamines aussi euh voilà
puis quand on a 20 ans on réfléchit pas
forcément avec tous ces
neurones je me souviens dans le
T les G me sautent dessus tout ça est
filmé tout les Anglais qu'on a croisé
ils avaient des coups dans la
gueule arrive une charge de
CRS les Anglais quand il voit les CRS
chargé
refl ils ont défoncé tout le monde SAF
moi
je peux vous assurer que ça tapé dur les
CRS ont du mal à à maîtriser la
situation et là de nombreux spectateurs
qui n'ont rien à voir avec tout ça
décident de partir parce que la
situation dégénère vraiment j'ai pas vu
le match au moment de la Marseillaise
j'ai évacué le stade pour aller
rejoindre mon frère aux urgences et là
ah il y avait des Anglais qui on s'est
retrouvé dans les urgences à se battre
dès le lendemain les journaux français
et plus encore les les journaux
britannique ont fait leur une et leur
gros titre sur la question c'est devenu
une affaire politique
majeure Margaret Sacher s'empare du
sujet et doit s'exprimer Jacques Chirac
du côté français condamne l'invasion des
des
Anglais je suis absolument outré par le
comportement des des supporters
britanniques qui se sont une fois de
plus conduit comme des voyons à l'époque
les pouvoirs publics français insistent
surtout sur la responsabilité anglaise
or les Français ont une large part de
responsabilité pour les houiganes
Français ce match va rester une sorte de
référence c'est le match où ils ont le
sentiment d'avoir dominé les
Anglais la déferlante houigan prend des
proportions inquiétantes
voici la tribune Boulogne où il se
rassemble un noyau dur 200 à 300 jeunes
qui n'appartiennent à aucun club de
supporters et des électrons près d'un
millier de supporters prêts à en
découdre et que rien ne semble devoir
arrêter dans une des tribunes du Parc
des Princes la tribune Boulogne se
rassemble des jeunes qui ont une forme
de fascination pour le football
anglais et de tout ce que ça signifie en
terme de de culture de
chant je dirais qu'il se la joue un peu
à l'anglaise d'une certaine
[Musique]
manière c'était la tribune notre tribune
on éta entre entre nous entre guillemets
c'est devenu un
territoire Boulogne tribune nationaliste
et
blanche moi suis allé avec un de mes
amis qui est
magrébin bon ça a été une grosse
expérience pour lui parce que il m'a dit
tu es sûr il va Marien m'aré j'ai dis
mais non si tu Arve quelque chose c'est
moi je mets mon m parce que tu es mon
ami j'ai dis mais tu restes à côté de
moi tu vas aux toilettes tu restes à
côté de moi il a vécu ça comme si je
l'avais emmené dans dans dans un endroit
[Applaudissements]
maléfique
[Musique]
quand canal plus rachète le
PSG la tribune Boulogne est un vrai
foyer de higanisme potentiellement
dangereux pour le club et pour son
avenir on peut crever on peut crever un
mec voilà on peut jamais dire ce qui va
se passer et c'est ça qui est bienon
sait pas ce qui va se passer c'est un
goû du risque en a qui monent au
Montblanc pour avoir du risque nous on
vient ici même si on sait qui sont les
casseurs on peut pas leur interdire
l'entrée la loi ne nous le permet pas
donc dans ce cadre-l notre marge de
manœuvre est effectivement encore
limité à l'époque la stratégie consiste
dans certaines banlieu mais aussi dans
certains stades à engagé en quelque
sorte des des grands frères si j'ose
dire des gens qui ont autorité sur les
jeunes qui sont dans les dans les
tribunes en l'occurrence et c'est ce que
va faire le parissgermain avec la
tribune
Boulogne mont proposé de rejoindre le
club en tant que responsable du
département supporter il s'agissait de
gérer tensions qui pouvait avoir ou qui
aurait pu y avoir dans une tribune il y
a toujours des personnalités qui
émergent des meneurs et Fabian était
l'un de
ceux j'avais été un élément je dirait
perturbateur à une certaine époque de ma
vie de faire le Higan ça m'a aidé on
était plus à même de gérer d'anticiper
et de de comprendre quand quelque chose
était pas
normal
c'était un rêve de
[Musique]
diamant c'était la meilleure équipe du
PSG pour moi humainement parlant et
financièrement parlant c'était une autre
époque c'est une photo qui a été prise
au parc des presses après un
entraînement avec tous les joueurs plus
le staff on a Ginola un très grand
monsieur George qui est un excellent
joueur Lama je suis ici entre Paul
legouen et Alain
Roche bon il fallait que je perde un peu
de poids quand même parce que j'étais
pas au niveau Canal Plus qui a quand
même une chaîne marquée à gauche ça
reste un peu problématique d'embaucher
des skinettes d'extrême droite non canal
plus aurait pu être un peu plus vigilant
sur certaines embauches parmi les
stadiers à l'époque je pense que Canal
essaie d'acheter une forme de paix avec
les tribunes et donc d'engager
recmentèsant sur le CV
politiqueig sont Conn et même souvent
identif il y a le groupe le plus visible
les
skin militant d'extrême droite affiché B
skin a été un des premiers il y a 10 ans
à trouver au stade un terrain d'action
parce c'est un terrain populaire parce
que le peuple est là il est dans la rue
et la rue c'est aussi par des Prin
c'estussi
St mais si c'est vrai sur moi il me DESS
il
me pourquoi il me tap moi je pense que
quelqu'un me ce dessus et me c'est des
barbares il n'y avait aucune raison
aucune raison vous demandez au garçons
aucune raison
hein les tentatives de récupération
politique dans la tribune Boulogne
qu'elles viennent des skinad ou d'autres
groupuscules politiques n'ont pas
réellement fonctionné en revanche les
idées se sont
diffusé C du bouffer du Bounou effectuer
des ratonnades autant d'expressions
utilisé par les voyou pour commettre des
actes de racisme les skinets ont agressé
un groupe de Magreb les automobilistes
qui étaient accompagnés de trois chiens
se sont acharnés à coup de Hachette sur
le jeune homme il va avoir une
accumulation de de fait d'hiver de
d'imigrés qui vont être agressés de de
concerts qui vont mal se passer jusqu'à
tempant qu'il a une réaction qui se m en
place on a vu qu' qu' abusaient quoi
comm à taper magb et tout ça et nous on
est contre contre contre tout ce qui
tout ce qu'ils font quo c'est je RRE un
SK
j si je suis pas dans son dit qu'il SK a
aucun problème la
FR il y a eu des chasseurs de skin parce
que il y a des skins qui sont
radicalisés à droite droite et que il y
a eu réaction de certains contre
ça
il y a des bandes telles que les Ducky
boys les Red Warriors et d'autres bandes
qui vont émerger à la suite et qui vont
vraiment faire la chasse à ce mecs
là la rue est un un terrain au même
titre que les urnes et nous on est des
gens qui avont vécu dans la rue et qui
par conséquent l'avons à cœur ne
comptons pas leur
abandonner on ne ni pas l'utilité de la
violence dans dans certains cas extrêm
mais on estime que l'extrême droite est
un cas
extrême ça va être d'abord une chasse au
look c'estd à tous ceux qui ont un look
de skin souviens un vieux flyer des
Ducky boys où c'est un avertissement en
disant attention si vouscé du SC la du
punk si vous êtes skin vous allez devoir
répondre en gros de de votre identité
quoi et devoir vous exp
[Musique]
comme tous les samedis au marché au puce
les dukiy boys contrôlent les promeneurs
il vérifie les insignes les badges et
même les paroles au moindre doute sur
l'opinion politique de quelqu'un il
[Musique]
frappe tap dessus comme des chiens ouais
si je me mets à gueuler et cetera je
cours dessus j'ai une matraque j'ai un
mateau je tape sur l'autre tap dessus
chaîne de vélo j'avais le hachoir de mes
parents il y a des moments j'avais des
marteaux un coup chou avais des des
couteaux leur truc c'était les serpettes
aussi il y avait des serpettes à
l'époque les serpettes c'est un couteau
d'électricien qui recourbé et ça ça
cicatrise pas
i c'est requis le chef des Docky Boys et
dans 10 minutes ça va être une boucherie
et là ils sont en train de se jauger et
l'autre lui dit espèce de sale connard
de Porthos on va massacrer qui sort un
flingam c'est
parti fou pas en
courant céit une
abomination les Duy boys tête Rocky 23
ans d'origine portugaise qui après avoir
quitté son travail devient le
porte-parole de
l'antiracisme le reste de la bande est
formé d'étudiants et de lycéens leur
emblème la croix celtique é d'un bras
pour r che il faut avoir plus de 18 ans
et pratiquer parfaitement les arts
[Musique]
martix
ça va quand même contribuer à faire
péricliter ces ces bandes de de
skin ça va créer moins de de vocation
c'estàdire que le petit jeune qui va
vouloir se mettre là-dedans ça fait
moins rêver de se dire c'est quand même
il y a un risque qui est vraiment réel
de terminer avec le nez cassé donc au
niveau du recrutement ça va être un peu
compliqué d'autre part il va avoir une
répression policière qui va s'abattre
sur tous les groupuscules naziskin qui
font que beaucoup de gens vont être
obligés de prendre de la
distance je me rappelle que batkin en
fait est venu me chercher
me dit ouais tiens j'ai une bande de
chasseurs de skin et il y en a un qui
veut se taper avec moi le chef et il y
en a un qui veut se taper avec toi et
donc on on a rend rendez-vous à un café
et là on se retrouve avec deux en face
de deux duky boy tu
vois alors Serge il va se taper avec le
chef làhaut qui était Rocky quoi et moi
je me retrouve avec ce garsl un black
tout en face de moi et ce jour-là je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas je ressentais
pas de haine envers ce
garslà c'était vraiment étrange tu vois
je ressentais plutôt je sais pas de la
sympathie tu vois mais je je sais pas
j'étais j'étais perdu dans ma haine j'ê
tu vois et et en fait c'est le dernier
souvenir que j'ai que j'ai eu en étant
skin c'est que je suis sorti en fait de
troker et en me disant que j'allais me
taper mais en fait j'ai tout
arrêté il peut avoir une lassitude de la
part de de ces personnes des combats
dans la rue ou tout simplement là je
peux faire son effet
aussi au bout d'un moment il peut avoir
une vie de famille qui s'installe une
vie professionnelle et donc passer à
autre chose tout
simplement ça dépend aussi qu'est ce que
vous entendez par skin abruti violent
[Musique]
et j'ai toujours été comme comme je suis
aujourd'hui c'estàd que quelque part je
serai toute ma
vie bon puis maintenant j'ai plus j'ai
plus 20
ans je vois les choses différemment et
avec un peu plus de recul je ne regarde
plus dans la masse je regarde la
personne je trouve stupide débile de de
de de s'en prendre à quelqu'un enfin de
s'en prendre à quelqu'un pour sa sa sa
couleur de peau ou sa religion
après tout le monde voit pas les choses
de la de la même
façon B on est tous partis en
sucette je pense que bah il y en a qui
ont
été un peu subjugué par tout
ça d'autres qui sont partis pour se
protéger don moi par exemple je suis
parti assez tôt je suis parti pour me
Sever parce que j'en avais marre de
courir après la 12 la bande des s'est
arrêté pour certains parce qu'ils
avaient découvert d'autres choses audelà
des il y a la vie
et un moment on a envie d'une vie
paisible on a envie de décompresser
complètement c'est comme sortir de la
guerre on a envie de rentrer à la
maison petit Willy ça m'a permis d'être
ce que je suis
aujourd'hui j'ai même du mal à revenir
dans ce
personnage il a fallu quand même des
années pour enterrer tout
ça il y a beaucoup de skinettes qui
viennent frapper à ma porte et puis pas
détendre tatouer partout et cetera et je
suis vraiment surpris et c'est
merveilleux quelque part c'est que bah
ils se mettent à méditer ils se mettent
à penser
différemment donc naturellement la haine
à un moment c'est une impace
j'avais mal en moi je sais que j'avais
frappé beaucoup de gens j'ai eu la cause
dans cette vie d'amener des gens à une
idéologie destructrice donc j'avais
envie de demander
pardon vois pas où il y a à se
repentir c'est quoi concrètement qui qui
mérite une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
repentance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que cette série vous a plu un
grand merci à Aurélie Simon et Nicolas
Dumont avec qui j'ai réalisé ce
documentaire un grand merci également à
Mathias ilon et Jean-Christophe Marco et
toutes les équipes de brut qui ont
participé à sa fabrication n'hésitez pas
à poser un like et à vous abonner pour
ne rien rater de nos prochaines vidéos
et sur ce je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle grande
histoire